I'm passionate about getting talent back to
work really for three different reasons.
One, and frankly it may appeal to some of
your viewers, I'm a taxpayer.
And anything that we can do to reduce recidivism,
keep people off of the rolls as an expense,
a government expense and a prison, as taxpayers,
is a positive.
So there's that part of me.
We have 7.3 million open jobs, and only 6
million people currently looking for jobs,
which means we have a talent shortage.
And if we can do anything to eliminate that
talent shortage, that's 1.3 million people,
roughly.
Every year some 700,000 or so people are released
from jails and prisons in America.
So we can use some of that population, that
700,000-person population, to make a dent
in that 1.3 million-person deficit.
So it's just practically smart.
And then the third part of me, which is more
humanitarian based, is people who have made
mistakes should be deserving of a second chance.
It is just I mean, because all of us have
made mistakes; some have been caught, some
haven't.
But these people have presumably paid their
debt to society.
And if the idea is: I make a mistake at 25
years old.
I go to jail for five years or prison for
five years.
And then I get out.
What do I have to look forward to if, forever,
I'm going to wear the scarlet letter, Convict,
the C, that says I'll never get another opportunity?
Life is over, then.
The holy grail of this would be if we could
identify people who are six months, a year,
away from release and begin giving them transitional
skills: work skills, life skills.
Think about this.
I was just meeting with someone who's been
incarcerated for 25 years.
The cell phone, as we know it, didn't exist
then.
So when they come out, they're going to have
to get adjusted to all of that.
The world has literally transformed in 25
years.
So in an ideal state, we would begin helping
them transition back into a world that they
pushed the pause button on two and a half
decades ago.
And we've got to catch them up pretty quickly
so that they acclimate and don't recidivate.
That's number one.
But once we do get them out, the most important
thing we can do is get them back to work housing
and work.
And they're sort of inextricably intertwined.
But housing is critical.
And we've got to find places for people to
have a permanent place.
Mind you, they've had housing for some significant
period of time.
And on the outside, absent that, there's an
instability that makes them more vulnerable.
And then you've got to pay for that housing,
which is where the job comes in.
We employers have to reach out to this population
and let all of our biases go away.
And we really do have to overcome our own
biases.
We talk about implicit bias, unconscious bias.
People think, oh, that's just in the context
of race and gender.
Well, the fact of the matter is we have a
lot of biases, one of which is a bias that
we have against the formerly incarcerated.
And maybe it's because of television and everything
that we see in movies and the characterizations
of people who are in jail, but all of that
comes through, whether we're conscious of
it or not, when we are talking to someone
who we know has been incarcerated.
We have some interesting research that says
roughly 80% of HR managers say, 'I'm interested
and would be willing to hire the formerly
incarcerated.'
SHRM's research says there is no bias at that
level.
Where we get into the bias and have had it
and seen it historically was customers and
other employees.
Those are the biggies.
You know, there's this NIMBY concept, which
says, 'Yeah, I like the idea of hiring the
formerly incarcerated, but not to sit next
to my daughter at work.'
So Not In My Backyard that's the NIMBY concept.
And so we've had to work on that.
Fortunately, we have some new research that
says employees themselves, as a result of
this narrative changing, and we're repositioning
the formerly incarcerated, have said, 'I'm
OK.'
Three-quarters of employees have said, 'I'm
OK with you bringing people into the workplace
for non-violent crimes.'
Similarly, about three-quarters of customers
have said, 'For non-violent crimes, I'm willing
to buy from a company that openly hires the
formerly incarcerated, a product or service.'
They're willing to do that.
Those were two major hurdles in the past.
And what we're seeing is as a result of us
changing the narrative these are not bad people.
They are people who made mistakes.
And that every one of us has made them and
is entitled to a second chance we're changing
the narrative around hiring the formerly incarcerated,
which is why SHRM is so committed to it.
Again, partially, employers just need to fill
this deficit.
America's birth rate has been on the decline
since about the year 2000.
So we don't have the luxury of refusing to
give opportunities to any large population
of people.